JUAN.
IT'S OUR EIGHTH ANNIVERSARY.
HERE WE GO.
DEMOCRATS APPARENTLY RUNNING OUT
OF REPUBLICANS TO ATTACK.
BATTLING WITH NANCY PELOSI AND
AOC SUGGESTING CRITICISM OF HER
AND OTHER FRESHMAN DEMOCRATS IS
RACIST.
CORTEZ SAYING THAT IT'S OUTRIGHT
DISRESPECTFUL.
NANCY PELOSI ISN'T BACKING DOWN
BUT NEITHER IS IN THE AMOUNT OF
CONCENTRATION OF ATTENTION, I
THINK IT'S WORTH ASKING WHY.
>> DO YOU THINK SHE HAS RACIAL
ANIMUS?
>> NO.
ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Dana: OF COURSE NOT.
SHE JUST SAID THAT THE DIDN'T
REALLY MEAN IT.
>> I KNOW THAT JUAN MIGHT
DISAGREE BUT I WANT THE BEST FOR
THE DEMOCRATS, I DO.
EVERY PARTY BENEFITS FROM A
STRONG COMPETITOR.
THEY ALWAYS GET BETTER.
I DON'T WANT THEM TO EAT
THEMSELVES ALIVE.
IN WOKE CULTURE, IT'S NOT ABOUT
COOPERATING OR UNITING.
IT'S ABOUT DELINEATING.
I AM NOT LIKE YOU.
I AM XYZ.
COLOR, ORIENTATION, GENDER,
DISABILITY, ALL OF IT HAS BECOME
INTERSECTIONALITY GAME OF IS
BETTER.
WHO IS MORE OPPRESSED.
TO WIN, YOU HAVE TO LABEL
EVERYONE ELSE INTOLERANT SO WHAT
YOU'RE LEFT WITH IS THE TINIEST
PARTY.
IT'S ALL BASED ON NARCISSISM.
WHO CAN BE THE MOST WOKE AND GET
THE MOST ATTENTION AND IT'S AT
THE EXPENSE OF YOUR ALLIES.
WHEN SHE WAS SAYING SHE WAS
TARGETING WOMEN OF COLOR, SHE
WAS SAYING SHE WAS BEING A
RACIST.
>> Dana: BUT THEN SHE SAID
SHE'S NOT.
SHE PUSHES ON NANCY PELOSI AND
THEN PUSHES BACK, PULLS BACK.
>> Juan: IT'S BIGGER THAN
NANCY PELOSI.
I THINK SHE'S VERY CLEAR THIS IS
ACTUALLY NOT A CLAIM THAT
NANCY PELOSI WAS RACIST.
AND BOY, WAS THERE BLOWBACK FROM
NANCY PELOSI'S CAUCUS.
BLACKS AND LATINOS SAYING THIS
IS CRAZY.
LOOK AT HOW DIVERSE THIS
CAUCUSES AND THAT'S THAT'S
BECAUSE OF NANCY PELOSI.
THERE WAS BLOWBACK IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THE COMMENTS MADE ABOUT
MODERATES, ESPECIALLY SOUTHERN
DEMOCRATIC MODERATES, DANA.
SMOOT     SOME OF THEM ARE BLACK
SMOOT     SOME OF THEM ARE BLAC.
HE SAID WAIT A MINUTE.
I THINK SHE'S GETTING BLOWBACK
WITHIN THE CAUCUS.
I THINK PART OF IT IS THAT
PEOPLE ARE RELUCTANT -- WE ARE
RELUCTANT TO TALK ABOUT
GENERATIONAL DIVIDES IN OUR
COUNTRY.
WE LIKE TO TALK ABOUT RACE.
>> Greg: WE LOVE TALKING ABOUT
GENERATIONS.
WE HATE TALKING ABOUT RACE.
THEY WENT AFTER MAYOR PETE.
>> Juan: HANG ON.
LET ME FINISH THIS POINT.
I THINK WE AS A COUNTRY DO NOT
SAY YOU KNOW WHAT, THERE'S HUGE
GENERATIONAL DIVIDE IN THE
COUNTRY AND HUGE GENERATIONAL
DIVIDE AMONG DEMOCRATS, WITH THE
YOUNGER PART OF THE COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW, MOSTLY DEMOCRATIC,
HEAVILY DIVERSE IN TERMS OF
RACE, IMMIGRANTS, AND THE LIKE.
THE OLDER PART OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS MORE -- I
THINK IT'S DIVERSE BUT --
>> Greg: BUT THE LOVE ONES --
THE YOUNG ONES LOVE BERNIE.
THE YOUNGER PROGRESSIVES ARE
FLOCKING TO BERNIE, NOT TO
MAYOR PETE.
IT'S NOT GENERATIONAL IS WHAT
I'M SAYING.
LET ME EXPLAIN IT AGAIN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: THE YOUNGER PEOPLE
MIGHT IN FACT LIKE BERNIE OR
LIKE A MORE PROGRESSIVE POLITICS
BUT THEY ARE REALLY ANGRY THAT
THE OLDER FOLKS AS THEY SEE IT
DON'T RESPOND TO THE BULLYING,
THE PUNCHING THAT COMES FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THEY SAY HOW COME YOU GUYS DON'T
FIGHT LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
WHY DON'T YOU PUNCH BACK?
THE OLDER CROWD IS SAYING HEY, I
KNOW HOW TO COUNT VOTES ON THE
HOUSE FLOOR.
I KNOW HOW TO WIN ELECTIONS.
ALL YOU GUYS TO HIS TALKED ABOUT
CLICKS ON TWITTER.
>> Dana: NANCY PELOSI CALLED
THEM THE SQUAD.
>> Jesse: THAT ELEVATES THEM
BY GIVING THEM A NICKNAME.
I DON'T KNOW IF THAT WAS THE
BEST TECHNIQUE.
JUAN, THE OLDER DEMOCRATS TRIED
TO STAGE A COUP AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
I THINK THEY HAVE BEEN FIGHTING
THE PRESIDENT PRETTY HARD THE
LAST TWO YEARS BUT I ALSO
STRONGLY DISAGREE WITH GREG.
I WOULD SEE THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
DESTROY ITSELF, EAT ITSELF
ALIVE.
THEY HAVE UNCORKED THIS VIRUS,
THIS IDENTITY POLITICS VIRUS AND
NOT EATING THEM AND NOW THEY ARE
UPSET ABOUT IT.
REALLY?
YOU'RE UPSET.
THE LAST FIVE YEARS, ANYTIME YOU
CRITICIZE BARACK OBAMA, RACIST.
CRITICIZE OMAR.
ISLAMAPHOBIC.
CRITICIZE THE CAPTAIN OF THE
U.S. SOCCER TEAM.
SEXIST AND HOMOPHOBIC.
THE CHICKENS HAVE COME HOME TO
ROOST, TO QUOTE THE PASTOR OF
BARACK OBAMA.
IT'S SAD BECAUSE THE ONLY TIME
YOU PLAY THE RACE CARD IN THE
GENDER CARD IS BECAUSE YOU DON'T
HAVE ANY CARDS LEFT TO PLAY.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SAID RIGHT HERE
WHEN YOU CITED THE DEMOCRATIC
LAWMAKER.
SHE SOUNDS LIKE A REPUBLICAN.
WILLIAM LACY CLAY, MALE DEMOCRAT
FROM MISSOURI.
WHAT A WEAK ARGUMENT TALKING
ABOUT AOC BECAUSE YOU CAN'T GET
YOUR WAY AND YOU'RE GETTING
PUSHED BACK.
YOU RESORT TO USING THE RACE
CARD.
THAT'S UNBELIEVABLE TO ME.
THAT'S WHAT REPUBLICANS HAVE
BEEN SAYING FOR SO LONG, A WEAK
RESPONSE WHEN YOU CAN'T PERSUADE
TO MAKE AN ARGUMENT AND I WILL
SAY LASTLY, THEY HAVEN'T BEEN
SINGLED OUT.
THEY SINGLED THEMSELVES OUT.
THEY WERE THE ONLY FOUR PEOPLE
TO VOTE WHILE 240 OTHERS VOTED
THE OTHER WAY.
AND THEY HAVE ALL BEEN LIGHTNING
RODS SINCE THEY GOT IN.
THEY ARE ALWAYS GETTING ALL THE
ATTENTION.
NANCY HASN'T SINGLED THEMSELVES
-- THEY'VE DONE IT TO
THEMSELVES.
>> Dana: CAN I MAKE A POINT?
I'M GOING TO MAKE A POINT.
THE SQUAD ONLY HAS FOUR VOTES
RIGHT NOW BUT THEY DON'T NEED
THAT MANY MORE VOTES IN ORDER TO
CAUSE NANCY PELOSI REAL
HEADACHES.
IT WOULD TAKE 18 VOTES FOR THEM
TO NOT BE ABLE TO PASS THINGS.
IF PEOPLE GET FRUSTRATED WITH
THE ESTABLISHMENT, THAT COULD
HAPPEN.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THERE TO
BE A BALANCE OF ENERGY.
YOU KNOW WHEN YOU GO TO DINNER
WITH ANOTHER COUPLE AND THEY GET
INTO AN ARGUMENT IN FRONT OF
YOU.
THEY ARE BICKERING.
IT'S ACHY AND IT MAKES EVERYONE
UNCOMFORTABLE.
>> Greg: I ENJOY THAT.
>> Jesse: I ENJOY THAT.
>> Emily: DO IT AT HOME.
IT'S LIKE A SORORITY SQUABBLE.
MORE THAN GENERATIONAL, IT'S A
MAJORITY DIFFERENCE.
I AGREE THAT THE SQUAD SINGLED
THEMSELVES OUT.
THEY SHOWED UP ON THE FIRST DAY
WEARING THE SAME AND THEY ARE
AGHAST AT THE THOUGHT --
>> Dana: LIKE ON WEDNESDAYS WE
WERE PINK?
>> Emily: TOTALLY.
MOVING FORWARD, PELOSI HAS TO
PROVE TO HER CENTRIST DISTRICT
THAT AOC AND THE SQUAD ARE NOT
SETTING THE AGENDA.
SHE NEEDS TO HARNESS THE ENERGY,
LIKE I SAID, OTHERWISE YOU CAN
LOSE THE SPEAKERSHIP OF THE
DEMOCRATS TO HOLD OR MAINTAIN
THE HOUSE MOVING FORWARD.